But before I show you an actual phase
diagram, I want to just take a moment
and try to explain to
you how this can be.
And we're going to do this by
just drawing little pictures
and just thinking to
ourselves, how could you
imagine packing fats together?
So remember, I told you that
triglycerides-- and this is really
a general fact for all fats-- but
triglycerides actually consist
of these two arms, with this
one long arm that's stuck to it.
And if we start to think to ourselves,
just draw on a little doodle pad,
how is it that we're going to
stack these things together,
there are really at least
two ways that you can do it.
So one is that what you could
imagine doing is taking the long arm
and stacking it in such a way, like
it's shown in this picture, where
the long arm is actually--
that is, the single arm,
is actually adjacent to the double
arms in the layer before it.
So this picture is what's
called double chain packing.
What you see is that the
long arm of one molecule
is on top of the double
arm on the other.
And they basically flip back
and forth from layer to layer,
which gives rise to the packing.
So there's also another
logical possibility,
which is what people call the triple
chain packing, in which what you do
is you put the two double
arms on top of each other,
and you put the single
arms on top of each other.
So you basically align the things so
that the single arms are like this,
and the double arms are like this.
That's shown in this picture.
And when you do that, that's
called triple chain packing.
And that's a different way
of packing the triglycerides.
Now, these two different
packings have different energies.
It might be more sticky
to do double chain
or more sticky to do triple chain.
And whether it is,
what is true, actually,
really depends on the
details of the fats.
I mean, so for example, if you could
just imagine as a thought experiment,
if you had a saturated
fat in the single chain,
then the saturated fats might
like-- the single chains might
like to stack together very well,
whereas if the unsaturated fats were
in the chains, then they're
sort of harder to stick.
And then, of course, the heads
with the two double chains,
that could be a different packing--
stacking interaction all together.
And it really, as you can
see from listening to me,
it gets a bit complicated to figure out,
just from thinking about it alone, what
the different stacking behavior is.
And this is really something
which is an experimental subject.
It can be empirically determined
by studying the phases of fats
and by looking under the microscope,
under a very powerful microscope,
to find out how the
molecules are stacked.
OK so with that as
background, I now want
to show you the phase
diagram of chocolate.
And I'm going to try to relate
this to what I just said.
So this is the phase
diagram of chocolate.
So chocolate has, as I
said, six crystalline phases
that vary in temperature from
18 degrees to 36 degrees.
So the lowest phase, which
people call phase 1, cleverly,
has a melting temperature
of about 18 degrees.
The second phase, which people
call phase 2, is about 22 degrees.
And then there are other phases.
There's phase 4, which is 34
degrees, and phase 6, which
is 36 degrees, and so on and so forth.
And these are the six different phases.
So what do I mean by different phase?
What I mean is, well, for one thing,
it melts at a different temperature.
It just comes apart.
If you made the material
out of only that phase,
and you heated it up to
the melting temperature,
then it would come apart
at that temperature.
And I also mean that if you were
to look at the structure, that
is, the way the molecules
are packed, they're
actually different in each of these
different phases, which is the reason
that it melts at different positions.
Now, what's interesting
about these numbers,
if you just think about my little
experiment with my piece of chocolate
a little while ago, is that if you
remember that body temperature-- that
is, your mouth is 37 degrees.
And your hand is-- let's say
it's 28 degrees or something.
If you want to find a material
out of this phase diagram, which
doesn't melt in your hand
but melts in your mouth,
you can see, really, the only options
you've got, even from the get-go
are phases 5 and 6, the two
highest phases, maybe phase 4.
It's close to the borderline.
But phases 5 and 6 are
really what you have.
And in fact, it turns out that 5
and 6, and in particular, phase 5,
is the phase that you
need to hit in order
to make the chocolate
that you know and love,
and that we saw so spectacularly
illustrated by Henrique.
Now, if you think
about preparations, you
can immediately see from
just looking at this diagram
and thinking about how
it is you're ever going
to do this why it is so
hard for the home chef,
or for somebody who's inexperienced like
me, to make chocolate in their kitchen.
It's because you somehow have to
basically get the cocoa butter-- which
you can buy cocoa butter, or you can
just take chocolate and melt it, like,
put it at very high temperatures,
and you will basically
get for yourself a mix of cocoa butter.
But then, the question is, how do you
get it to only crystallize in the phase
at phase 5, which is what you want?
I mean, clearly, if you cool it to
a low temperature like 22 degrees,
then it can cool into all
of these different phases.
So what are you supposed
to do to make this happen?
And the complexities of making chocolate
are all associated with this issue.